[Musique]
s est invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
marie-amélie le fur bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes une
jeune retraitée du sport en tout cas
l'un des plus beaux palmarès du
handisport france et triple championne
paralympique entre autres choses en 100
m 400 m et saut en longueur aujourd'hui
présidente du comité paralympique et
sportif français les jeux paralympiques
de pékin commence dans trois semaines
avec une belle équipe de france on va y
revenir dans un instant vous avez mis un
terme à votre carrière professionnelle
après les jeux paralympiques de tokyo
l'été dernier vous avez décroché
l'argent en saut en longueur vous avez
connu cette atmosphère très particulière
sans public ou presque pour cette
compétition avec le stress des tests
antico vide qui sont la poussée à
l'extrême aux jo de pékin qui ont
commencé il ya quelques jours ce que
c'est forcément une expérience
différente là pour les athlètes qui
vivent les jeux en ce moment oui je
pense que c'est forcément une expérience
très différente comme vous le disait
très justement il ya la crainte des
tests au départ toujours cette crainte
finalement dû du virus sur sur la
période des jeux qui peut vous interdire
de de participer à cette compétition
vous préparée depuis quatre années mais
en tout cas sur les jeux d'été il ya eu
aussi cet effet positif
finalement deux par le fait qu'on ne
pouvait pas sortir de la bulle sanitaire
de nous rapprocher les uns les autres au
sein de la délégation française donc
c'était des jeux qui était différent
l'absence du public est aussi compliqué
parce qu'on sait très bien que des
sportifs ils ont besoin aussi de leurs
proches de leur famille et finalement du
public pour les porter mais on est
malheureusement maintenant adapté je
pense que enfin on fera avec et les
sportifs sont sont préparés et
l'objectif pour ces jeux de pékin c'est
toute cette fête qu'on pourra pas avoir
lors des jeux sur les sites de
compétition de pouvoir l'offrir aux
sportifs lors de leur retour comme on
l'a fait après tokyo d'ailleurs ces jeux
à pékin ont lieu dans le contexte
politique que vous connaissez sur fond
de boycotts diplomatique vous avez vécu
vos les jeux de pékin en 2008 c'était au
premier vous savez de quoi on parle
comment est ce qu'on vit une situation
comme ça quand on est sportif on met de
côté complètement on se déleste de tous
ces enjeux-là les sportifs partent avec
leurs propres convictions leur propre
regard sur le pays hôte mais ils sont
véritablement concentré aussi sur leurs
performances sportives c'est une
préparation qui dure quatre ans c'est un
objectif ultime notamment jeux
paralympiques gagner une médaille
paralympique voilà c'est je pense c'est
la consécration ultime pour nos sportifs
ma paralympiques même si dans cette
équipe de france on a déjà des multiples
médaillés donc l'objectif pour hausser
de se concentrer sur eux sur la
compétition sur le fait d'aller chercher
des médailles et surtout donner le
meilleur d'eux mêmes lors de ces
compétitions vous quand vous étiez en
compétition vous étiez fixé des limites
des pays où vous étiez dit j'irai pas je
me suis pas forcément posé la question
parce qu on est vraiment en fait engagé
dans un processus sportif on suit ce
calendrier international après on a la
capacité de choisir effectivement les
meetings mais les jeux voilà c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui marque votre
carrière si une compétition
extraordinaire autant par la visibilité
par le retentissement des médailles que
par l' aventure humaine que l'on vit
durant ces jeux et c'est compliqué je
pense pourvoir pour des sportifs d'être
privé de cette magnifique compétition
vous allez y aller j'ai la chance de
pouvoir effectivement accompagné notre
note délégation française les yeux aux
paralympiques de pékin en 2008 c'était
vos premiers jeux marie-amélie le fur
vous aviez 20 ans c'était quatre mois
après votre accident de scooter à
l'issue duquel vous avez été amputé sous
le genou gauche landi sport à l'époque
c'était ultra confidentiel on en est où
quinze ans plus tard je pense que quinze
ans plus tard on a franchi un cap on l'a
vu notamment après les jeux de londres
après les jeux de de tokyo il ya un
véritable engouement qui se met en place
autour des jeux le public français qui
est demandeur qui a envie de suivre ces
jeux paralympiques des sportives
paralympiques qui sont de mieux en mieux
identifiés pour la première fois cet été
les jeux paralympiques ont eu la chance
de faire la une de l'équipe c'était
vraiment une première pour cette
délégation française mais il faut qu'on
continue qu'on continue à aller plus
loin pour faire en sorte que à l'issue
des jeux de paris pour préparer les
prochains jeux des et divers vraiment
cette équipe de france les visages qui
font cette équipe de france soit
beaucoup plus connus reconnus par le
grand public et on a aussi tout un
accompagnement du des journalistes à
faire pour faire en sorte que vous
compreniez mieux ce qui est l'écosystème
des départs à sport ce que sont les jeux
paralympiques ce qu'est la
réglementation donc voilà donc c'est
vraiment l'objectif en tout cas à
l'échelle du comité paralympique que
l'on s'est fixés et c'est vraiment de
parler de notre sport de nos sportifs
comme des sportifs de haut niveau qui
réalisent des performances qui
transmettre des émotions et qui ont la
singularité d'être en situation de
handicap alors justement quelques mots
de cette équipe paralympiques française
qui va commencer la compétition ils sont
pas parties encore ou alors sur le point
de partir dans quelques jours à pékin
peut-être un mot du porte drapeau qui
s'appelle benjamin davier effectivement
donc notre porte drapeau qui a été
révélé il ya deux semaines maintenant
qui est benjamin davier cris nordique
ski nordique un athlète confirmé déjà
trois fois champion paralympique
il vient participer à ses troisièmes
jeux à pékin et il sera le porte drapeau
le porte-parole le capitaine d'une
équipe de france actuellement composé de
dix sept athlètes très athlètes quatre
guides qui sont répartis uniquement donc
3 sport le ski alpin le snowboard et le
ski nordique donc il ya de grandes
ambitions pour cette équipe de france
appuie un cochon que ça avait été 20
médailles 7 en or voilà on espère au
travers de cette équipe de france qui
est composé à la fois date est confirmée
mais aussi des athlètes en devenir aller
chercher de très beaux résultats et
surtout obtenir la médiatisation qui est
qu'il méritait peut-être une autre star
de l'équipe mary bausch est
effectivement marc ébauché un très très
grand palmarès je pense l'un des plus
beaux palmarès paralympiques en tout cas
en france marie est confrontée
actuellement une une recrue de la
concurrence a vraiment des athlètes
chinoises qui sont très fortes mais lors
des derniers championnats du monde elle
a montré qu'elle pouvait encore être
présente qu'elle était en capacité de
gagner de nombreuses médailles en tout
cas moi c'est une athlète déterminé que
j'ai eus récemment et qui aura envie
d'en découdre sur les pistes à pékin on
l'a dit tout à l'heure vous avez vous
marie-amélie le fur peut-être le plus
beau palmarès non pas du para athlétisme
français mais de l'athlétisme français
tout court en neuf médailles
paralympiques plus d'une dizaine de
médailles mondiales dont quatre titres
de championne vont corriger si je me
trompe
si vous aviez concurrents ont concouru
auprès de valides vous auriez été non
pas parce qu'une star nationale mais
sans doute international comment est ce
qu'on vit parfois ce décalage de
notoriété ont fait pas forcément la
comparaison
je pense que malheureusement les
sportifs paralympiques subi ce manque de
médiatisation comme de nombreux sportifs
dans des sports qui ne sont pas aussi
porteur que la natation que l'athlétisme
donc voilà on apprend à vivre avec
l'objectif je pense pour nos sportifs
c'est vraiment de leur donner la
sécurité la capacité de se préparer le
plus sereinement possible
je pense effectivement que ce manque de
médiatisation il est important de de le
faire changer de le faire évoluer
notamment avec ses jeux de paris 2024
qui sont une opportunité extraordinaire
et ben finalement de permettre aux
français de découvrir cette équipe
paralympiques cette équipe de france
quel que soit le sport d'appartenance
est aussi de permettre à ces sports de
vivre en dehors des jeux paralympiques
je pense que ça c'est un des véritables
enjeux et ça permettra peut-être voilà
deux d'avoir des sportifs qui sont plus
reconnus qui médiatiquement sont plus
porteurs parce qu'encore une fois il ya
vraiment de très très beau palmarès dans
nos équipes de france le fait qu'on
ramène les les
les parts d'ombré les sportifs
handicapés à leur accident de vie à leur
parcours est ce que cette il faudrait
s'en défaire à la longue ou au contraire
continuer à raconter ses parcours de vie
précisément parce que c'est parce qu'il
ya aussi ce handicap que la performance
est si exceptionnel il est impossible de
gommer la singularité de noah tête parce
que ça fait partie d'eux parce que ça
fait partie de leur parcours de vie mais
il faut pas en faire peut-être le langue
de communication premier je le disais
tout à l'heure nos sportifs qui sont en
équipe de france nos sportifs en devenir
c'est avant tout des sportifs de haut
niveau qui sont engagés dans
l'entraînement qui sont engagés dans un
processus d'autres performances qui
réalisent des performances mais ils ont
un parcours de vie bien souvent qui est
attéby qui est singulier par la présence
du handicap et je pense qu'il faut le
l'esprit il faut en parler parce que ça
explique aussi la façon dont sont
réalisés ces performances là donc c'est
peut-être de trouver un meilleur
équilibre par rapport à ce qu'on fait
actuellement entre la situation de
handicap le parcours de vie est vraiment
raconter et permettre la compréhension
du programme public de ce qu'est la
performance du sportif en situation de
handicap je pense à tes au cur enquêtait
sur ce plateau y'a pas longtemps qu'il
ne disait qu'il adorerait qu'un jour on
lui parle exclusivement de sa coupe de
cheveux et non plus de ce qui lui était
arrivé dans la vie votre objectif bien
sûr y'a pékin là sur le court terme
c'est 2024 c'est que l'équipe de france
corrigez moi si je me trompe
paralympiques soit présente dans la
vingtaine de sports que compte le
paralympiques mme aujourd'hui ça veut
dire bien sûr à voir les athlètes et
puis ça veut dire aussi que derrière il
faut y avoue il faut qu'il y ait le
développement du sport l'accès à la
pratique aujourd'hui quand on est
porteur d'un handicap en france ça
concerne des millions de personnes avoir
accès simplement un sport du quotidien
ça reste une gageur effectivement c'est
un véritable enjeu un derrière les les
jeux de paris 2024 c'est d'obtenir un
héritage très fort principalement sur le
développement de la pratique des
personnes en situation de handicap faire
en sorte que demain c'est 10 à 12
millions de personnes en situation de
handicap en france aient accès beaucoup
plus facilement une pratique sportive de
proximité avoir un club près de chez eux
qui est en capacité de les accueillir
parce que l'équipement est adapté parce
que les encadrants les bénévoles sont
formés parce que la pratique sportive
qui est dispensé est adapté à la
singularité de de la personne anciaux
son handicap donc ça c'est véritablement
le l'enjeu de demain la médiatisation et
le renforcement de la médiatisation et
est un axe de travail
on a sorti tout récemment le guide des
paras sport à destination des élus aux
sports parce qu'on pense aussi que si
demain les politiques sportifs sont plus
adaptées sont et permettre de faciliter
l'accès à la pratique sportive les
personnes soient sans handicap ce sera
un levier complémentaire qui sera
apporté aux territoires donc l'objectif
de ce guide c'est vraiment d'accompagner
les élus aux sports dans la
compréhension du mouvement paralympique
dans la culture à sion aux enjeux pour
vraiment avoir des politiques sportives
sur l'enjeu de la formation d équipement
du sport à l'école soit vraiment adaptée
à notre public voilà c'est un gros
chantier mais je crois que vous n'êtes
pas du genre à vous reposer merci
beaucoup marie-amélie le fur d'être venu
ce matin sur le plateau de paris direct
très beaux jeux paralympiques à vous il
ya toute l'équipe de france et on pense
à ceux qui sont déjà à pékin on attend
avec impatience la médaille d'or très
bonne journée